Building a relationship with an investor
is just like building a relationship
with a colleague.
It's something that fosters
over a long period of time and
you get out of it what you're
willing to put into it, and
you can't think of investors as people
you go to when there's a crisis.
You have to think of them as people
you can go to on a regular basis and
share ideas and get feedback and
react to that feedback.
And you can't, you have to figure out
how to balance doing exactly what
the investor says verses taking your own
path and figure out where that fits.
If you always do exactly
what the investors say,
that's probably not a recipe for
success.
Likewise if you ignore all of
the advice that you're getting,
that's not going to work out very well.